[Musique]
bonsoir les petits
la voilà mais pourquoi es-tu nounours
pas trop savez-vous ce que dit un petit
nuage à sa maman non
voyons pas trop il lui dit maman je
voudrais faire fluide pluie
il ne faut pas grand chose pour t'amuser
pluie pluie
c'est un petit nuage qui dit à sa maman
j'aurais fait plus
vous la connaissez oui
[Rires]
mon ami Marcel me l'a raconté
aujourd'hui
elles sont faites vos histoires moi je
préfère m'amuser à faire des pâtés sur
la table
pourquoi pas
est-ce que c'est du sable comme celui de
ton patron
celui du marchand de sable est un sable
merveilleux
on dort toujours les enfants avec oui
[Musique]
comme moi voyons d'abord oui
les enfants du monde entier
écouter
il va vous le chanter
[Musique]
je suis le marchand de stable la journée
est finie il faut être raisonnable
c'est le moment d'aller au
tous les jours sur mon nuage nous nous
revient avec moi et nous partons en
voyage
dans le ciel par-dessus les toits
[Musique]
je n'ai pas d'autre bagages
qu'un pipeau
enchanté et du haut de mon nuage
je sais même mon sable d'or et
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants du monde
à demain
bonne nuit moi je continue ma ronde
bonne nuit à tous les petits
[Musique]
bonne nuit ma juliette a